[Music]
hello i'm natasha vito moore
i am the executive director of humanity
plus one of the world's largest
transhumanist non-profit educational
organizations
in this session
how to live forever my question is how
not to die
one of the
strongest influencers on the issue of
not dying is the historical lore the
narrative that has been woven
in our script
throughout the eons throughout the
centuries and all cultures as a matter
of fact
it's integrated and provides that script
a foregone conclusion for all humans
that we are going to die so when we wake
up we're born with this notion that we
are going to die
what would it be like just if we shifted
that a bit
and took away that certainty and turned
it into
probability a possibility or even an
uncertainty
that possibly we might not die
now let me
qualify that
meaning that we may not die or remove
that foregone conclusion i mean that
based on our biological system
and the maximum lifespan for every human
which is largely the maximum lifespan
for our species which is approximately
122 to 123 years
if you have good genes or if you're born
with a mutation or a disease that is
inherited
in your genetic legacy then perhaps it's
quite different
you may have a much shorter lifespan or
a lifespan that cannot be healthy
because of the disease that you're
comparing
[Music]
so let's remove that certainty turn it
into a possibility a probability of
uncertainty and take a look at what are
the causes of death
those causes can be looked at as
very obvious for many of us eat well
exercise get plenty of sleep reduce
stress and surround yourself with kind
loving people that care about you
so this purposefulness in life would be
one of the caveats for not dying because
those are the obvious ones but i'm going
to introduce to you a portfolio for you
to invest in and this portfolio let's
just call it a life portfolio was going
to be three different areas that you can
invest in for your own life
[Music]
the bottom line is don't die and we say
this every day to ourselves
to our children to our parents to our
loved ones our friends and even everyone
that we see in hardship a hurricane the
fires the wildfires in california we got
i hope no one dies
in the wars around the world
in the ill areas of illness and
especially covid19 where people have
less medical care and are
very densely populated we go hope they
don't die
so it's a natural instinctive desire
that we don't die however if it's a
foregone conclusion then why does time
matter does it matter if you die at five
or 95
so that we put
value on someone's worth age worth
rather than their merit worth or their
love worth we usually consider someone
young to be more important than someone
old
so let's change that mode of thinking
too
the reason why in my view that we've
invested so much in this narrative this
historical lore that travels across
centuries and cultures
so it's not geographical and it's not
age related it's a timeless notion
civilization has invested
in this need for death to tell their
stories
life is not meaningful without death
the old should die and make way for the
young
you've outworn your stay overpopulation
global warming
we tend to start placing the emphasis on
our deficits our problems based on too
many people older people
disrespected people
those in grades
our biases our prejudice also come into
this equation
we spend more time more money and more
effort
on
continuing this narrative then
addressing the problem so then the
question is what's the problem the
problem is disease and aging
the battle against aging and disease and
the finality or the foregone conclusion
of death
wages on regardless of the advances in
science the advances in technology and
the minds of people
[Music]
that are historical the genius mind of
each person and those who we say are
genius who the inventors who create
marvelous
opportunities have yet to solve this
problem have yet
to end this war
so i'm introducing now my life portfolio
it's about smart investing not just in
your livelihood but in yourself and i
think the greatest investment we can do
is in ourselves to make our lives
meaningful purposeful
and to share to be
benevolent
to be generous
and importantly to share our knowledge
with others
the accumulation of human knowledge is
worth sharing and so we need to invest
in the information
not the misinformation and we'll get
into a little bit of why i think
investing in information is so important
so now we approach how how we're going
to do this
how is always a good question so how
with a portfolio strategy i've broken it
down into three specific areas the
conservative investment in your life
your prolongation your preservation of
your life staying alive
the moderate growth
and the high risk aggressive investment
we'll take a look at this and it's i've
created a bit of a
play on your portfolio investment and
finances but there is no greater
investment than your life so
here
diversity is essential
so what does this portfolio look like
i call it the super longevity portfolio
and you'll see i have three different
quadrants here the conservative the
moderate growth and the high risk
aggressive growth
i've broken it down into chronological
age and i'm someone who
is not an ageist and i don't even like
quantifying or qualifying a person based
on their age but because we live in a
world that is time-based age is
important when we're thinking about our
lifespan because as we age we are more
prone to certain diseases
and if we want to answer the question
how to live forever then we need to
consider this
okay so let's look at the first quadrant
i have the ages 20 to 40. that's when we
start thinking about
our aging usually we don't think about
it prior to that unless you have a
disease and illness or an injury but
let's just go to the mainstream area
here 75
of our investment should be in
eating exercising the healthy things
that we do um
getting enough sleep not partying too
much certainly not drinking too much or
doing too many drugs but staying healthy
and that largely is
eating well kato diet or maybe a little
bit of calorie restriction but being
aware that
we need a certain amount of protein we
need our vegetables of course and we
need our fats so that is based on your
personal um
biological system and what your needs
are you may have allergies to things but
basically that that very conservative is
doing the basic things to live as long
as possible as healthfully as possible
to get to that maximum lifespan of 122
to 123 years approximately that's our
shelf life
so
you want to take care of your body but
also your brain and the brain is still
very plastic at this time the plasticity
the learning the acquiring of
information
is really good so this is a low-risk
strategy
and it's a fixed genomic portfolio
so this would be for the younger
generation when we get into the
chronological age of middle age say 40
to 70 somewhere within that spectrum we
want to take a little bit more risk and
it's moderate growth
the primary goal of this law longevity
is not to die so
we want to generate
current information on all the
breakthroughs and there's breakthroughs
going on on a daily basis and gene
therapies genomics
biotechnologies nanomedicine stem cells
looking at reversing aging the the
telomeres and the enzyme the telomerase
what causes aging looking at hormones
our peptides our proteins
our whole cellular system and with that
information now this is really important
in the moderate growth portfolio
that you gain information you absorb
information you do the moderate
you have
20 in the moderate you've already
maintained your healthfulness by this
time by eating well getting enough sleep
reducing stress
those basic fundamental needs for your
mind and body but here we're going to
gather information because you don't
want to take too much risk and i'll
explain that in a moment to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you